-Performing her new single,
"That's How It Goes,"
with a little help
from the Roots,
please welcome Zoe Wees!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ -I've been picking myself up
off the floor ♪
♪ Every damn night
I start a war ♪
♪ I got all these problems
on my mind ♪
♪ I've been trying hard
to survive ♪
♪ This world is cruel ♪
♪ You love then you lose ♪
♪ Until your heart stops ♪
♪ All my life, all my life,
all my life ♪
♪ Yeah, I've been told ♪
♪ That that's how it,
that's how it goes ♪
♪ Yeah, you gotta fight
on your own ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Who needs enemies,
friends like these ♪
♪ When I need them,
they don't call ♪
♪ They all got their reasons,
their demons ♪
♪ They don't know ♪
♪ Devil by my side
tryna take my life ♪
♪ Social control ♪
♪ But that's how it goes ♪
♪ -Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ -And that's how it goes ♪
♪ -That's how it gooooes ♪
♪ -Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ -That's how it goes ♪
♪ -So nice, I feel like
I'm walking on fire ♪
♪ Anything that keeps me alive ♪
♪ I want to visit her tonight ♪
♪ I know the devil pride
inside ♪
♪ And this world is cruel ♪
♪ You love then you lose ♪
♪ Until your heart stops ♪
♪ All my life, all my life,
all my life ♪
♪ Yeah, I've been told ♪
♪ That that's how it,
that's how it goes ♪
♪ Yeah, you gotta fight
on your own ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Who needs enemies,
friends like these ♪
♪ When I need them,
they don't call ♪
♪ They all got their reasons,
their demons ♪
♪ They don't know ♪
♪ Devil by my side
tryna take my life ♪
♪ Social control ♪
♪ But that's how it goes ♪
♪ -Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ -And that's how it goes ♪
♪ -That's how it gooooes ♪
♪ -Ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ -That's how it goes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]